welcome to this video new Mariano's yes
I have some some bell is ringing no not
the name I don't know what I play him
two times okay let's play that this
reverse grand prix for once yeah the
worst version of the Grand Prix sm funny
enough somewhat more interesting than
the usual one with the wide going for
the setup I think this is quite
interesting he's playing this like he's
totally ignoring everything here maybe I
can but a 3 and so that's quite slowish
let's see how is he going to play this
now III maybe f4 Bishop 83 is serious he
has to do something you cannot just play
this maybe but not sure it definitely is
dangerous this F for Bishop h3
okay absol absolutely no no way not to
fly it in total gung-ho stallion look
the idea I probably want that the temple
knight on c6 is going to get sacrificed
probably why it's maybe not even
necessary i came to deform huh maybe
not okay come on this everything points
through this working so i won't them
lose on time now to try to calculate it
so okay so um take them take them
threatening a look at three now yes
they're okay three I can take with the
pawn
no it's not working can take on f 2 with
the pawn
night if tuna that's not working
I wanted to take a three but you can of
course cheek with the e porn or silly as
that I did not see that one
well I was stupid the tech was super
strong even without any any any
sacrifice I could just play 90 form
now it's it's almost dangerous as we see
here Luke f2 was forced check check
winning the queendom can pre move that
white resigns I did it was bad I pleaded
badly I pleaded badly I have to go an
idea form with a with a great position
simply this is not working i think a
computer says it is working whoa why
yeah i have to start with this of course
i have to stay actually I confused to
move autumn this was my prob I wanted to
take him I had seen this line I had seen
this line and I just I just screwed up
the move order this is why it wasn't
working so that was the problem so I
have to take on g3 first again this is
not this is not not okay he has to take
here here and take them and white is
winning ok computer wise why this
winning it's it's still a bit murky but
objectively white should win the be
seven points too much but as we see it
can easily check it can easily check
happen that white stood blunders for
being so much under pressure yeah you
know what I don't think when he played
this very in a very relaxed fashion yeah
with bishop T 2 a 3 a 3 for example it's
just a lot of a temper because I take
that on c3 anyway and also d4 hmm not
sure about all that but ok no
for ya before I was just like oh no no
defensive move and a good way to defend
usually is III now just to have this
additional protection now okay and when
did it around here it gets very
problematic a computer wants to go
Quincy one for a better defensive set up
after this year 90 forever is strong
yeah I saw it but I was too tempted by
the other thing this is also an attack
without any material without any
sacrifice and winning actually compass
on minus 1.8 or something but this is
also good i just have to take here this
is much better this is not working
because of this this thing and here
there's simply no age 3 after the
capture so he's basically out of out of
ideas now yeah i'm i played this too
quickly right i played this quickly I I
had this I had seen this this had these
ideas but I turned to move on around it
also goes bad okay well thanks for
watching